Bitte schön.
Guten Morgen, mein Name ist Salih Tash. Ich bin heute Stationarzt. Ich würde mit Ihnen ein annamnesiges Spiel durchführen.
In Ordnung vor Sie.
Sehr gerne.
Erstmal würde ich gerne ein paar Fragen bestätigt Ihrer persönlichen Daten stellen.
Dann komme ich gleich zu Ihren aktuellen Bescheiden.
Wie heißen Sie Witze?
Mein Name ist Vogel. Anja Vogel.
Können Sie Ihren Vorname und Nachname buchten?
Mein Nachname wird geschrieben V-O-G-E-L.
Genau.
Und mein Vorname ist Anja Anton, Nordpol J-A.
Anja.
Okay. Frau, oder?
Ja.
Wie alt sind Sie Witze?
Ich bin geboren am 1. 3. 1972. Ich bin 51 Jahre alt.
Erstruh?
März 1972.
Wie groß und schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,65 m groß und 92 kg schwer.
Okay.
Was fützt Sie zu uns? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ich habe seit ungefähr 3 Tagen Schmerzen im Oberpauch.
Das macht mir Sorgen.
Haben die Schmerzen plöstig angefangen oder lagst du schläf?
Ja, also eingeschleichtend nachts haben die angefangen.
Sie ziehen sich jetzt auch durch den Tag über.
Sind die Schmerzen eher dunkel, brennend, ziehend?
Wie können Sie einschätzen?
Eher so drückend, würde ich sagen.
Manchmal aber auch stechend.
Streit und Schmerzen, ich bin zwar auf.
Oder immer weim Oberpauch.
Manchmal rechts und links, manchmal in den Rücken.
Aber eher so in die rechte Seite.
Haben Sie einen bestimmten Auslöser beim Werk, bevor die Schmerzen auftreten?
In der Nacht auftreten, in der Nacht.
Können wir sagen, dass die Schmerzen in der Nacht verschlimmen?
Nö, in der Nacht begonnen.
Haben Sie etwas gegen Schmerzen eingenommen oder etwas gemacht?
Ich habe zu Hause über Profen gehabt.
Wie viel Tag ist das?
Vier Jahre, glaube ich, was ich drauf kaufe.
Eingenommen oder mehrere Mal haben Sie eingenommen?
Ich habe das jetzt jeden Abend genommen, damit es die Schmerzladen ist.
Aber ich habe nicht mehr geholfen.
Ja, ein bisschen.
Aber mittlerweile wirkt das nicht mehr.
Ich muss schon auch tagsüberwärtsch nehmen.
Sie sind wegen dieser Beschwerden bei einem Ausgleich schon gewesen?
Oder erst mal heute?
Nein, Sie haben Mittwoch angefangen.
Ich bin heute hier, ich bin noch nicht beim Ausgleich gewesen.
Haben Sie sich übergegeben, bebruschen?
Ja, zwei Mal.
Wie sieht das Bruschen aus?
Nur mal, gar nicht, gar nicht, weil ich habe jetzt die letzten zwei Tage auch nicht viel gegessen.
Ich verstehe.
Ihr Apatit ist weniger geworden, oder?
Ja, weil es viel tut, ich habe Schmerzen.
Fühlen Sie sich fibrig?
Nein, nicht wirklich.
Gibt es noch begleiteten Symptome, außer der Schmerz und Fiber haben Sie kein Fiber, schwindelig?
Ich habe kein Schwindelig.
Ich habe so ein voller Gefühl, ich habe ein bisschen Blähungen.
Bemerkensort brennen?
Nein, nicht wirklich.
Schmeckt ihr?
Oder soll es ausstoßen?
Nein, eigentlich auch nicht.
Ich verstehe.
Außer dass die Schmerzen, haben Sie noch vielleicht Kopfschmerzen, Bruschen, oder?
Nein, ich habe keine Kopfschmerzen.
Haben Sie bemerkt, ob Sie in letzter Zeit auch dazu genommen?
Ich habe mich nicht bewogen, aber ich denke nicht, dass ich viel abgenommen habe.
Leidend unter Nachschweiß oder Stufbruschen?
Nein.
Ich würde gerne noch ein paar Fragen oder Ihre Vorerkrankungen stellen.
Leidend unter chronische Erkrankungen?
Chronische Erkrankungen.
Ich habe Bluthochdruck.
Seit wann?
105 Jahre.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen ein?
Eine Tablette, das ist Ramie-Pril.
Wie ist die Dosierung?
50 Milligramm.
Ich habe noch eine Tablette für die Schilddröse.
Wie heißt das?
L-Tyroxin.
Das heißt, dass Sie Schilddrösen unter Funktionen haben?
Genau, das hat mein Arzt gesagt.
Wie ist die Dosierung?
Ich habe sie seit mehr als 10 Jahren.
Wie viele Mikrogramm?
75.
Gibt es noch andere Erkrankungen?
Nicht als Juste?
Wollten Sie schon mal auf Paris?
Nein, bisher noch nicht.
Ich war noch nie stationär im Krankenhaus.
Ich war bei der Geburt meiner Tochter.
Da war ich im Krankenhaus.
Gibt es etwas Auffälligkeiten beim Schulgang?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Ich habe nicht bemerkt, dass ich in der Stuhlgang
die Erkrankungen habe.
Ich habe keine Beschwerden damit.
Darf ich fragen, ob Ihre Eltern noch im Leben sind?
Ich habe noch im Leben.
Die haben auch Zucker,
die haben auch Bluthochdruck.
Meine Mutter hat auch Zucker.
Die beiden haben das.
Aber außerdem leidet Ihre Mutter
unter Schilddose.
Ihr habt auch Bluthochdruck.
Ihr Fazer, nur Bluthochdruck.
Und ihr habt auch Kollesterine-Höhungen.
Ihr habt auch Kollesterine-Höhungen.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Leben Sie mit Ihrem Mann?
Ja, wir leben so in einer Familie.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Eine Tochter.
Ist sie gesund?
Ja, Gott sei Dank.
Das folgt mich zuhause.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe eine Schwester.
Ist sie auch gesund?
Ja, gut.
Rauchen Sie?
Manchmal, ja.
Wie viele Zerätzen rauchen Sie?
Ja, ich rauche Zigaretten.
Ich rauche 5 bis 10 Zerät am Tag.
10 bis?
5 bis 10 Zerätzen.
Können wir sagen, täglich?
Ja, mindestens 50 Zerätten.
Auf der Arbeit ein bisschen weniger.
Zuhause ein bisschen mehr.
Trinkensatkohl?
Selten.
Wo hast du ihn gesehen?
Kommt immer drauf an.
Manchmal am Wochenende.
Selten.
Wein oder Bier?
Genau, so was.
Darf ich fragen, ob Sie bisher
Drogenkontakt gehabt haben?
Früher in der Jugend.
Wegen der Studium?
Ich habe nicht studiert.
Was machen Sie vom Beruf?
Ich bin Kassiererin.
Gib mir die Schwierigkeiten bei der Arbeit?
Nein, immer der gleiche Stress.
Sind Sie alle gegen etwas?
Ich bin nicht ein Hausstor.
Ich bin ein Hausstor.
Wie aussieht es sich?
Mit Niesen und Gaul.
Wie heucheln wir von?
Ich habe keine Heucheln, weiß ich nicht.
Besten noch, Allergien gegen Lebensmitteil?
Nein.
Leiden Sie uns eine Unverträglichkeit?
Nein, gar nicht.
Ich kann leider alles vertragen.
Deswegen bin ich auch so schwer.
Nehmt diese Ansicht, andere Medikamente ein.
Wie ich sage, manchmal über Profäen, wenn ich Schmerzen habe.
Aber kommt damit an.
Heute geschmessen, die sich schon haben.
Erstmalig sind auch getreten.
Das erste Mal habe ich diese Schmerzen.
Okay.
Das ist normalerweise Herzstoppern,
Herzrasen, Dispneu.
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Okay, ich bin am Ende mit meinem...
Wissen Sie denn, was ich habe?
Noch eine Frage, was Sie in der Zeit im Urlaub haben?
Nein.
Ich war zwar im Urlaub, aber nicht im Ausland.
Ich war in Deutschland.
Was glauben Sie denn, was ich habe?
Genau, ehrlich gesagt, ich kann nicht genau sagen,
aber es könnte mit den festen Ursachen zusammenhangeln.
Beispielsweise
können Sie eine Galenbilase
entfinden oder Probleme sein.
Oder mit Magen Probleme sein.
Aber um eine richtige Diagnose zu stellen,
muss ich noch ein paar Maßnahmen befürchten.
Was machen Sie denn, wenn ich frage?
Aber natürlich.
Ich würde jetzt die Körpelig untersuchen.
Genau, und ich wollte abenden,
außer dem, ich wollte die Teilverheimnisse messen.
Genau.
Und je nachdem würde ich
als Bildgebendes verfahren,
veranlassen, aber jetzt nicht vielheit.
Genau.
Bildgebendes verfahren, was heißt das?
Mutterscheid,
Abtomöse, Nographie, genau.
Okay.
Ja, genau.
Sie müssen hier bleiben.
Multistationär hier bleiben.
Ehrlich gesagt, es scheint nicht so.
Jetzt aber nachdem wir alle Ergebnisse
gesammelt haben,
finde ich mir richtig sagen, genauer sagen,
ja, die Gerichte sagen.
Ich muss nicht operiert werden oder so, ne?
Jetzt kann ich nicht sagen,
dass die operiert werden müssen.
Aber mal schauen.
Okay. Genau.
Okay.
Ich würde erst mal ernsthafte,
ersthaft Erklärungen ausschließen.
Meinen Sie das Krebs?
Ich meine nicht.
Jetzt Krebs, aber...
Ich hätte gedacht, das ist einfach eine Markenreinigung.
Es könnte sein.
Aber es könnte auch was Schlimmes sein.
Ich würde sagen,
es könnte sein.
Aber es könnte auch was Schlimmes sein.
Ja, genau.
Aber ich kann nicht jetzt sagen, genauer sagen...
Ich würde meinen Mann anrufen.
Ich muss da kommen.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich möchte nicht jetzt ihn anrufen.
Aber mal schauen.
Erst mal führen wir ein paar Massnahmen durch.
Also Sie glauben, dass ich was Schlimmes habe, ja?
Ehrlich gesagt, ich kann nicht jetzt sagen,
dass Sie etwas Schmerzes haben.
Aber Sie haben gesagt, ernsthaft Erkrankungen ausschließen.
Also kann es doch was Schlimmes sein.
Normalerweise müssen wir erst mal
im Notaufnahme ernsthaft Erkrankheiten ausschließen.
Am Sonntag feiern wir.
Mehrkantinfarkt durchs Herzinfarkt
oder vielleicht...
Normalerweise...
Normalerweise muss nicht...
Es sei nicht...
Ein paar...
Heißt, infakten kommen,
können Sie mit Oberbauchschmerzen kommen.
Okay.
Heute am Sonntag, wie gesagt,
im Notaufnahme sind wir jetzt.
Und ich würde gerne erst mal...
Genau.
Dann warte ich jetzt hier oder?
Ja, genau, bitte.
Ich werde Sie auf dem Notaufnahme helfen.
Okay, danke schön.
Hocam, ich denke, Salih war gut
für das erste Annemnis.
Ja, das war gut.
Ein bisschen war er aufgeregt.
Ja, leider.
Ja, das ist gut.
Haben Kollegen andere Fragen?
Noch andere Fragen?
Salih, bitte.
Unsere Fragen.
Was bedeutet...
Eine gute Wörter...
...schnell.
Ich bin ein Schütter, der auf einer Schmerzskalafon
null ist, wobei ich ein sehr leichter bin.
Ich bin ein Schütter, der auf einer Schütter schiebt.
Hocam, was...
Ja, ja, genau.
Echt?
Antwort, Hocam?
Ja, ich habe 6-7.
Gibt es bestimmte Ausslöse für die Schmerzen?
Nach dem Essen?
Ja.
Nach dem Essen ist das wirklich mehr?
Okay.
In der Nacht.
Aber wenn ich morgens was esse,
dann habe ich die Schmerzen mehr.
Also sind die Schmerzen nach dem Essen mehr.
Nach dem Essen mehr.
Wie viel Kissen benutzt du?
Ich habe aber keinen Kissen.
Ich habe aber keinen Aufstoß.
Ich habe auch keinen Zutun.
Keinen Zutun, okay.
Sie haben gesagt,
keine Herzrasen und keine Atemnot.
Bei Bewegung
können Sie bemerken,
es ist nicht auf Bewegung auslösbar.
Nein.
Die kommen und gehen die Schmerzen.
Stechender, drückender Schmerz.
In der Nacht
ich habe sehr viele Schmerzen.
Eine Italian-F british Schmerzen
ich habe auch viele Schmerzen.
Ich habe auch viele Schmerzen.
Dann habe ich viele Schmerzen.
Ich habe ein Körner.
Können wir dir auch ein-fall,
würden Sie?
Nein.
Nein, Nein, Nein, Nein, Nein, Nein.
Riesli birender könne wir sagen l'atainisch.
Rettig wirnisch mehr könne wir sagen ja.
Okay. Danke schön.
Okay.
Wir dekerin, ne, ja, wir dekorin.
Wir dekerin, ne, ja.
Ja, ho Cem, wie viel yaren rachnizi?
Ich hab schon, ja, schon seit 30 Jahren, ne.
30 Jahre.
Ich habe auch keine Geld-Ferbung gemerkt.
Ich bin auch nicht Geld oder so.
Ich wollte auch fragen, ob ich da habe.
Hat sich Ihrer Gewicht in letzter Zeit mächtig verändert, Roger?
Das hat er gefragt. Ich habe aber gesagt, ich habe mich nicht gewogen.
Ich denke nicht.
Ich habe auch keinen Nachtschweiß.
Hab ich auch nicht. Nein.
Danke schön. Ich denke, ich werde die Fragen in der Zeit gehalten.
Können wir als Alsatzgeist ein paar mal?
Ja, gerne.
Halli, bitte schön.
Ja, das ist ein schwieriger Teil.
Nein, das ist schwierig.
Ich bin ein Pürofer.
Okay.
Bitte schön.
Guten Tag Herr Obat.
Ich habe vor kurzem eine neue Patientin gesehen.
Dann würde ich sie Ihnen vorstellen.
Ja.
Frau Vogel ist eine 51-Jährige, 1 Meter 65 Große.
Sie hat 90 Kilogramm schwerer Patientin.
Sie ist heute bei uns seit 3 Tagen wegen der Stichende Druckende,
der diese wirrende Oberbauchschmerzen vorgestellt hat.
Das Weitere berichtet sie, dass die Schmerzen in die Rücken ausstrahlen würden
und die Schmerzen in der Nacht erst mal aufgetreten seien.
Postprandial.
Ja, genau.
Auch allerdings hat sie gemeint, dass es nicht mehr Schmerzen,
Postprandial, Verschilimett, sei.
Nein, sie hat nicht mehr Postprandial empfangen.
Okay.
Ja, sie hat angefangen.
Als begleitet sein von...
... der Universität.
Die Schmerzen wurden bei einer nummerischen Radixekalar bei 6 und 7, wie 7, liegen.
Genau, begleitet sein von...
... MESIS.
Sie hat gesagt, dass sie zweimal Erbruschen habe.
Okay.
Genau.
Dagegen haben sie täglich über Profen 400 Milligramm.
Begleit sind Tome...
Wir haben gesagt...
... Salle, begleit sind Tome haben sie gesagt und dann nur MESIS.
Andere begleit sind Tome, bitte sagen sie.
Kein Fieber, kein Schmied oder kein Sortbrindeln.
Nein, völlig gefühlt, Bilehungon.
Bilehungon.
Nein, der Patient hat...
Ich habe gesagt, Bilehungon habe ich gesagt.
Okay, ich habe gesagt.
Ich wüsste ihn nicht.
Okay, begleitet sein von MESIS.
Bilehungon.
Methorismus.
Genau.
Ich habe sie zweimal erbrochen.
Erbrochen?
Erbrochen, genau.
Die Fragen nach Fibers, Wetzigow, Rotbisinen,
Säures ausstoßen, ein bisschen Porokalgie,
Nachschwass, Schüttelverrot, Wuldefenein.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist unauffällig bis auf Inappetenz
in nähre dreitagen.
Zwei Tage, hat gesagt.
Zwei Tage, zwei Tage.
Stuhlgang und Wasserlassen, ich bin auch unauffällig.
Aus Vorerkrankungen leiden sie unser arterialer Hypothenie
und Hypotheriose.
Dagegen nehmen sie 50 Gramm Ramifril
gegen arterial Hypothenie und Erdroxin, 75 Mikrogramm.
In der Familienanamnese ist ...
Wie viele Jahre?
Seit fünf Jahren arterial Hypothenie.
Seit zehn Jahren leiden sie unter Hypotheriose.
In der Familienanamnese ist erwähnungswert,
sowohl die Mutter und als auch der Vater
unter arterial Hypothenie leiden würden.
Außerdem leiden ihr Mutter unter Hypotheriose auch.
Sie haben geschwitzt eine Schwester, sie sei gestohnt.
Sie ist frei, sei reihratet und lebt ihr Mann,
ihr Mann und sie habe einen Tochter, sie ist auch gestohnt.
Sie rauchert ungefähr seit 30 Jahren
vom fünf bis zehn, drittentäglich,
siehtzglitcher Alkohol,
selten Wein und Puppier,
die Frage nach Drogen wurde verneint.
Sie sei allergisch gegen Hausstoffen,
Staub,
ohne Tee, Staub,
mit D, an Ende.
Sie sei allergisch gegen Hausstoffe,
die ausserzig Niesen-Juchenreis.
Jukrals.
Die Frage nach Unverträglichkeiten wurde verneint.
Sie ist kassieren.
Sie hat gesagt,
sie ist ein sehr guter Surat.
sie hat gesagt,
sie ist lautet Ulcus ventriculi.
Warum?
Ulcus ventriculi.
Warum glauben Sie,
dass Ulcus ventriculi ist?
Nach dem Essen
haben die Schmerzen angefangen,
die betreten,
die Schmerzen sind.
Woran müssen Sie noch denken?
Auf jeden Fall.
Sie ist eine Frau.
Sie ist Adipylus.
Sie hat ein Kind.
Sie ist über 50.
Sie ist eine Frau.
Sie ist Adipylus.
Haben sie den Patienten gefragt, ob er einen geilen Leiden hat, ob er einen geilen Stein hat?
Ja, ich habe nicht mehr gefragt.
Man sollte immer fragen, wenn jetzt die Patienten auch Medikamente nehmen,
Blutabnahme oder Schilddröse. Wann war der letzte Checkup beim Haushalt?
Wann war der letzte Besuch beim Haushalt?
Sollte man immer fragen, die Patienten erzählen nicht immer alles von selber.
Man muss das jetzt auch holen.
Ja, das ich dir.
Oder, Herr Hodja, hier Bluthock-Druck wird Medikamente gut eingebaut.
Sind Sie gut eingestellt aktuell, genau?
Oder kontrollieren Sie hier regelblutdruck, regelmäßig?
Richtig, ganz genau. Das ist eine gute Frage, die man stellen kann.
Wir sind nicht hier, da kommt es nicht, aber es ist ein bisschen.
Die Patientin hat, wir gehen noch mal gemeinsam durch,
ist nachts aufgetreten das erste Mal.
Sie hat die Beschwerden seit drei Tagen schon.
Sie hat ein tolle Gefühl, ein Druckgefühl.
Sie hat rezidivierende Schmerzen, vielleicht kolichartig, vielleicht nicht.
Das haben Sie die ganze Frage.
Und dann ist es immer nach dem Essen.
Und dann muss man schon dran denken, wenn es am Oberbauch ist,
wenn es in Rückrausstrahl auch rechtzeitig Bauchschmerzen hat,
Sie haben vollkommen recht an Ulcus ventriciulidencin pancretitis,
aber Sie hat kein Fieber, Sie hat keine grüttelförmige Schmerzen.
Sie ist das typische Beispiel für eine Gallensteinerkrankung.
Es kann auch eine chronische Schulle zu stittes sein.
Das wissen wir nicht.
Das sehen wir erst, wenn wir einen Ultraschall machen.
Ja, genau.
Das sind die Blutwerte.
Wichtig ist, dass Sie eine Pancretitis und eine Ausstießung können,
ob ein Ektorus besteht, also eine Geldfärbung der Haut.
Und Hodja, auf jeden Fall eine Iphereomyokaltympathik
bei der Differenz der Dürfen.
Auf jeden Fall.
Auf jeden Fall EKG in der Notaufnahme.
Sowas wichtig muss man definitiv machen.
Das ist ein Weg gegen Hinterwand im Pfad.
Ja, genau.
Auf jeden Fall.
Frauen weiß man nicht.
Ein Fassindrom.
Ja.
Bitte schön.
Was machen wir jetzt mit dem Patienten, Herr Sali?
Ich würde jetzt Sie körperlich untersuchen,
wie Teilparametramen ist und EKG schreiben.
Und ich veranlasse Abdomenzornografien.
Oder Sie machen das selber?
Genau, was selber.
Beim Blutspilz würde ich ALT, ACC, GGC, ALP, WC, ALP,
alles gut, was für das.
In Deutschland benutzt man GUT, GPT, nicht ALT und ASK.
Es gibt Kliniken, die das benutzen, aber hier in Nordrhein-Westfalen benutzen wir das nicht.
Versteht.
Kannst du sagen, lieber wird es.
Okay.
Niemand wird es.
Das ist Scholesstaseparameter.
Ich würde auch sicher ein bisschen tropen.
Kannst du machen?
Ja, genau.
Niemand wird es.
Lungen.
Aber das passt.
Herr Sali, Lungen Nachbarn, das ist ein Fassindrom.
Das ist ein Fassindrom.
Das passt.
Herr Sali, Lungen Nachbarn, deswegen Dedi-Mah auf jedem Fall?
Ja, ich würde eine Routaufnahme machen.
Dedi-Mah ist aber immer ein Problem.
Wenn jetzt die Patienten, wir haben ein Problem, wenn wir Dedi-Mah bestimmen.
Weil wenn wir Dedi-Mah bestimmen, müssen wir theoretisch eine Lungenembolie ausschließen.
Wir sind verpflichtet.
Deswegen würde ich Dedi-Mah nicht abnehmen.
Nur, wenn jetzt zum Beispiel, Sie haben meine Schule zu Stittes.
Sie haben erhöhte Entzündungswerte.
CRP ist hoch.
Leukenzutte sind hoch.
Das ist ein Problem.
Wenn Sie Dedi-Mah hoch haben, muss man leider auch eine Lungenembolie ausschließen.
Oder eine Trombolie aus dem Bein.
Warum?
Der Patient kann eine Zollistitis haben, aber auch eine Lungenembolie haben.
Deswegen würde ich das nicht abnehmen.
Nur, wenn ich nicht verweigte, dann würde ich sagen, okay,
Sie haben keine Gallenentzündung, Sie haben keine Herzinfarkt,
aber Sie haben Beschwerden.
Oder wenn das EKG auffällig ist.
Wenn Sie ein dickes Bein haben, wenn ich den Verdacht bei einer Trombose habe.
Wenn ich den Verdacht bei einer Lunge habe,
dann darf ich Dedi-Mah abnehmen.
Es kann sein, dass wenn Sie doch eine Lungenembolie haben
und Sie gucken nicht nach, wenn Sie erhöhte Dedi-Mah hat,
dann ist das ein erster Fehler.
Also lieber vielleicht nachmelden.
Sie haben keine Luftnutz, keine Belastungsdispel,
Sie haben keine Unterschädung für Dedi-Mah.
Und keine Akutabdomenschmerzen.
Keine Akutsystematik würde ich sagen.
Arbeitstagnose ist eher Oberbauch, Magen, Gallenblase
und Pankreas.
Und auch Herz natürlich.
Okay, Sie machen ein Blutbild, Sie machen eine Zuletztöße.
Genau.
Sie machen die Schulestasenparameter.
Und was könnte bei dem Patient, wenn es jetzt eine Schulzüstütte
oder eine Schulzüstolitis ist, es gibt ein besonderes Zeichen?
Erhöhte Lebewährze.
Erhört eine Lebewährze?
Wir wissen.
Welche Zeichen, Herr Kollege?
Er ist Murphy Zeichen.
Und andere?
Kurwa Zeichen.
Murphy Zeichen.
Und bei der körpärischen Untersuchung eine Kennzeichen.
Gummi Bauch.
Genau.
Kurwa Zeichen ist, wenn Sie die Gallenblase auch tasten können,
zum Beispiel.
Wenn die Gallenblase so hoch ist und Sie drücken drauf,
aber die Tasten, die Gallenblase,
das ist aber kein richtiger Schmerz.
Bei Murphy Zeichen haben Sie den Schmerz, wenn Sie einatmen lassen.
Haben Sie das verstanden, Sali?
Ja, genau.
Also könnte sein, muss aber nicht sein.
Wir haben zwei Richtungen für eine Gallenblase Entzündung.
Genau.
Aber während Utrecht sein können wir auch Sie einschauen.
Ja, genau.
Ob es einen Stau gibt oder Steinen.
Ob es eine intrahypathische, extrahypathische Scholespase gibt.
Ob es einen Gallenblasen Hydro gibt.
Ob es eine Scholezysdoletiasis gibt.
Ob es eine Schole-Dochole-Tiasis gibt.
Wenn Sie gut sind im Ultraschall, können Sie das sehen.
Wenn Sie noch nicht erfahren sind,
dann müssen Sie ein erfahrener Arzt dazurufen.
Ja, genau.
Und was machen wir mit dem Parallel?
Jetzt hat wir eine Scholezysdoletiasis.
Ich ordne erstmal Karenz an.
Karenz, was ist für eine Karenz?
Ich gebe Flüssigkeiten in der Yidraue Nösch.
Okay.
Und auch Schmerzmitteile.
Genau.
Und ich fange mit Antibiotikum an.
Nein, erstmal.
Aber erstmal abwarten.
Er hat eine Scholezysdoletiasis.
Oder Sie hat eine Scholezysdoletiasis.
Ja.
Wenn Sie nicht, Sie können überlegen,
ob man eine Antibiotikum machen muss oder nicht.
Es kommt davon an, ob Sie eine Scholezysditis hat
oder eine Scholegitis hat.
Dann ist Antibiotikum wichtig.
Aber wenn Sie nur eine Scholezysdoletiasis haben,
muss man nicht unbedingt eine Antibiotikum machen.
Beide Komplikationen denken wir Antibiotische Therapie.
Aber erstmal nicht denken.
Genau.
Haben Sie das verstanden, Sani?
Ja, genau.
Wenn Sie zum Beispiel im Ultraschall, Sie sehen,
die Garnblase ist dick.
Sie hat eine Dreistichtung.
Also Sie hat typische Zeichen.
Es ist ödomatös drum herum.
Dann auf jeden Fall.
Wenn Sie eine Scholezysdoletiasis haben,
dann sollte man schon Antibiotikum machen.
Aber wenn Sie eine symptomatische Scholezysdoletiasis haben,
also Sie hat die Beschwerden nur nach dem Essen abends,
Sie hat kein Fieber, Sie hat kein Nachtschweiß,
Sie ist nicht kaltschweißig,
kein Schüttelfrost oder sowas.
Dann muss man nicht unbedingt eine Schole an Antibiotikum machen.
Zulm, R Shp?
Nein, nein.
Herr Kollege, eine Frage.
Herr Kollege, was verstehen wir,
Gallechtau, das heißt Latanische Kulistasie,
aber was verstehen, was Dolunvia verstehen, oder?
Es gibt eine inkraftatische Scholezdase
und extraäktratische Scholezdase.
Wenn der Stein, es kommt darauf an, wo der Stein ist,
ist der Stein in dem Doktuscholodochus.
Dann kann es eine Intrat, dass die Leber dick wird,
dass die geilen Wege dick werden.
Extraäktratische Scholezdase ist, wenn der Doktuscholodochus dick ist,
der ist über 7 oder 9 mm, glaube ich, weiß ich nicht ganz genau.
Das kann man im Ultraschall sehen.
Wenn der Stein im Doktuscholodochus ist, die können sehen,
dann, oder der ist mit dem Fundibulum, also vom Gallblasen,
Ausgang in den Zollfingerrämmen, in die Papille,
dann sollten sie an ERCP machen, das ist richtig.
Oder vielleicht, da wird sie ein Gallblasen Fluss wieder haben.
Den Stein müssen sie rausnehmen und dann einfach einschmeißen.
Oder so, dass man die Ereignisse sagen kann,
die Scholezdase, die Scholezdase, die Scholezdase, die Scholezdase.
Nein, man macht ERCP.
Ja, ERCP.
Ein Liskot, die mit der Scholezdase, die Scholezdase.
Man kann auch ERCP und ERCP machen.
Scholezdase, Scholezdase, Pancreatografie.
Ja.
So, jetzt hat die Patientin nur, Sie sehen im Ultraschall,
keinen Zündungszeichen.
Alles ist gut, kein schönes Tasezeichen, aber Sie sehen,
dass sie Steine haben.
6, 7 Steine, 6, 7 Gallensteine.
Was empfehlen Sie der Patientin?
Ich würde empfehlen, dass die Patientin allgemein schuldig besucht.
Untersucht wird?
Ja, es könnte eine Operation bestehen.
Würden Sie eine Operation empfehlen?
Ja, genau.
Muss man diese Patientin operieren?
Ja.
Aber wenn ...
Sie sagen, es ist eine Operation, mache ich nicht.
Müssen Sie die Patientin operieren?
Eigentlich gesagt nicht.
Nein, Sie müssen nicht.
Ja, genau.
Aber Sie können der Patientin sagen,
Sie werden wahrscheinlich diese Schmerz immer wieder haben.
Ja, und vielleicht entschuldigt im Laufe des ...
Das kann zu einer Entzündung kommen.
Es kann auch zu einer Selbstes kommen.
Aber man empfiehlt auf jeden Fall eine Scholezistoktomie.
Ja, genau.
Aber Sie müssten die nicht heute operieren.
Ich gebe eine Schmerzmedikamente,
aktuell besteht keine Gefahr.
Sie haben einen Aufstau der Galle,
Sie haben auch keine Entzündungszeichen.
Wenn Sie sich operieren lassen möchten,
melden Sie sich bei uns oder bei Ihrem Hausarzt.
Dann können wir Ihre Operation elektrisch planen.
Aber müssen Sie elektrisch planen?
Man muss nicht planen.
Wenn Sie sehr starke Schmerzen haben,
und Sie sagen, ich kann das nicht mehr aushalten,
dann sagen Sie dem Chirurgen Bescheid.
Wenn der Chirurgen sagt, können wir morgen operieren,
dann können Sie morgen operieren.
Aber in der Regel, es ist ja kein Notfall,
dann können Sie sagen, gehen Sie nach Hause,
ich gebe eine Schmerzmedikamente mit.
Und Sie kommen bitte nächste Woche Montag
oder nächste Woche Dienstag elektrisch zur Aufnahme
und dann operieren Sie, oder die Chirurgen operieren.
Aber wenn Sie jetzt wirklich sehr starke Schmerzen haben,
müssten Sie die Patienten sowieso stationär aufnehmen.
Sie müssen hier intravenös die Kamente geben,
damit es keine Schmerzen hat.
Sie müssen hier helfen.
Und Sie können anbieten, Sie haben keine Entzündung.
Das ist alles okay.
Wir können Sie morgen operieren, wenn Sie möchten.
Aber man muss das nicht machen.
Man kann hier auf jeden Fall eine Nahrungskarenz empfehlen
und man muss das aber gar nicht machen.
Sie dürfen nichts mehr essen.
Möglich für die entterrale Ernährung, Kujan?
Ja, genau.
Ich dachte, wenn wir die Patienten stationär aufnehmen würden,
dann würde ich ...
Aber nein, Kujan, man empfiehlt,
man muss die Patienten aufnehmen,
man empfiehlt
eine vorübergehende Nahrungskarenz,
aber nicht auf Dauer.
Wenn Sie mehr als besser werden,
das sorgt dir dafür, dass die Gallenblase nicht belastet wird.
Ja, genau.
Dann kann man später wieder Kosten aufbauen,
mit Schuhenkosten.
Man kann zum Beispiel sagen,
die Spreisen, die nicht viel Fett haben,
also Fettarm, Zwieback, so was in der Hand haben.
Man sollte nicht sagen,
hier essen Sie mal das Hähnchen jetzt, oder so was.
Oder essen Sie mal Döner, oder so was.
Das wäre nicht so gut.